[Música]
o mundo muda e muda o tempo todo
revoluções acontecem desde sempre em
toda parte do mundo na nossa história
nós temos quatro grandes revoluções que
mudaram completamente a nossa forma de
lidar e quando a gente pára para
analisar a gente só vê a parte boa das
revoluções novos empregos novas
oportunidades esculturas tendências ea
gente esquece que essas revoluções só
aconteceram porque tinham problemas que
precisavam ser solucionados
e quando a gente olha o sinônimo de
revolução
a gente encontra palavras como subversão
transformação e inovação
todas as quatro revoluções mudaram
completamente a nossa relação com nós
mesmos com produtos serviços e meios
distâncias ficaram mais curtas conhecer
pessoas ficou muito mais fácil opiniões
viralizam com muito mais facilidade de
fato todas as quatro revoluções
revolucionaram as nossas relações e
século 18 século 19 século 21 em século
21 a uma cronologia unitária de
revolução para a revolução mas eu
audaciosa que sou digo que a quinta
revolução e está a caminho e que ela vai
vem antes da virada do século
talvez um século 21 e meio 21.7 e já tem
muita gente fazendo o papel de
formiguinha para que isso aconteça
e pra mim a quinta revolução vai ser em
ciências da vida e o que é ciências da
vida ciências da vida são todas as
inovações em estudos na área de saúde
animal saúde humana biotecnologia meio
ambiente e todas essas inovações
tínhamos da gente como as inovações
estudos em vacinas e remédios que
aumentará nossa longevidade a tecnologia
em pasteurização de leite que além de
tornar o alimento por muito mais tempo
nos ajuda a nossa nutrição a conservação
in vitro de espécies que estão entrando
em extinção para que mesmo que seja em
escala laboratorial ela perdure por
muitos mais gerações a utilização de
drones na agricultura para melhor
pulverização para reflorestamento um
plantio mais exato visando o aumento da
produtividade a utilização de energias
renováveis como biodigestores e
biomassas placas solares e deixando cada
vez mais de lado a energia não
sustentável como o petróleo
todas todas essas esses exemplos são de
inovações em ciências da vida e melina
quem é você pra achar que a quinta
revolução das ciências da vida
quando a gente pára para analisar as
quatro outras revoluções todas partiram
de dois princípios básicos o primeiro
princípio é que a sociedade passava por
problemas que precisavam ser
solucionados e atualmente nós também
passamos por inúmeros problemas
desmatamento poluição dos ares
o excesso de lixo consumismo em massa
a poluição do nosso ecossistema marinho
acabando com toda fauna e flora
por causa do excesso de plásticos que a
conquistar nossas águas
são problemas que nos acompanham
cotidianamente dia após dia ea segunda
premissa para que aconteça uma revolução
são pessoas que não aceitam aquela
aquela realidade de jeito nenhum
pessoas incomodadas com aquilo que está
acontecendo e atualmente 62 por cento
das pessoas
então que o nosso sistema entrou em
colapso mas na verdade nós otimistas que
somos
vemos que na verdade 62% das pessoas
estão propensas a gerar uma revolução e
pra mim é aí que se encontra a
oportunidade incrível pra esse colapso
maravilhoso girando mudanças revolução e
inovação
a inovação está por toda parte desde da
nossa relação com o celular que não é a
mesma de três anos atrás ea inovação em
ciência da vida foi o que mudou a minha
trajetória de um ano pra cá tem de fazer
sempre com que os meus valores governo
nem as minhas acções e sempre tomar
atitudes visão do meu amor pelo meio
ambiente desde redução do consumo de
bens retirada da alimentação animal da
minha vida e quando eu estava no segundo
ano do ensino médio
eu decidi que eu seria diplomata e que
eu ia representar o meio ambiente e
trabalhar na onu é é um sonho muito
audacioso mas eu tinha certeza que era
profissão exato que se encaixava comigo
e quando eu entrei na faculdade eu me
deparei com inúmeras oportunidades de
colocar o meu amor pelo meio ambiente em
prática de fato causa essa diferença e
uma dessas iniciativas que o conhecido
foi o startup u1 programa feita pelos
alunos da ufmg com a ideia de criar
modelos de negócios inovadores e
disruptivos mas eu confesso que eu só
quis participar do startup u porque o
tema desta edição era negócio de impacto
sócio ambiental e na hora que eu vi
aquilo eu sabia que era exatamente o que
tinha tudo a ver comigo que era tudo que
eu sempre quis e negócios de impacto
sócio ambiental são aqueles negócios
atrelados aos objetivos de
desenvolvimento sustentáveis da onu que
são chamados o de s
são 17 metas que a onu e todos os países
que a compõem
criaram em 2015 para que nós e todo
mundo consigamos algum
salas até 2030 e essas metas elas vão
desde igualdade de gênero vida marinha
indústrias sustentáveis e elas podem ser
divididas em quatro áreas distintas área
social institucional econômica e
ambiental
mas o que ciência da vida tem a ver com
a 10 tem a ver com inovação bom quando
existe uma inovação em ciências da vida
ela já nasce querendo resolver algum
problema no mundo
ela já nasce com esse propósito de
transformação
eu não parei por aí nessa minha vontade
de querer mudar o mundo de querer mudar
a realidade e deixar o meu cheirinho por
onde eu passava eu participei do startup
u entrei nessa maré de empreendedorismo
e eu desenvolvi um negócio em que a
nossa missão é ressignifica a nossas
relações com resíduos sólidos onde nós
trazemos de volta à cadeia produtiva
algo que seria descartado no mercado que
é chamada economia circular apresenta
pra vocês a gravar o nosso negócio de
ciências da vida na área de
biotecnologia e nós fazemos parte de 3
odst da onu
nós já nascemos com essa vontade de
querer fazer parte o décimo número 3 que
é de saúde bem estar
o ds número 11 cidades e comunidades
sustentáveis e o défice de número 12
consumo e produções sustentáveis e nós
enxergamos uma oportunidade para começar
o desenvolvimento de um negócio onde 85%
dos resíduos da produção da cerveja são
formados pelo bagaço de malte e esse
resíduo ele tem números aplicabilidade
sendo que hoje ele simplesmente
descartado
ele pode ser utilizado tanto para a
produção de papel pela quantidade de
celulose pra produção energética por
meio de biomassa para alimentação animal
e também para consumo humano
está aí o nosso propósito então nós
transformamos o bagaço de malte e
trazemos com ele um novo
em suma alimentício para consumo humano
que é uma farinha e essa farinha de
malte
ela é utilizada na produção de pães
bolos bruni e uma versatilidade receitas
e além de tudo essa farinha
apesar do resultado ter sido processado
e passado por outros processos eles pois
ela possui altos níveis de fibras
proteínas sais minerais inúmeros outros
benefícios para o corpo humano e ser
otimista e querer um mundo melhor fica
até mais fácil né e concordo com vocês e
por que então criar um negócio que seja
inovador que seja de ciências da vida e
que sejam atrelados aos objetivos de
desenvolvimento sustentável da onu
porque na verdade além da gente está
ganhando dinheiro
a gente está fazendo bem para o mundo a
gente está contribuindo cada vez mais
para que esses 17 objetivos sejam de
fato os alcançados e já deu pra perceber
que eu me encanto com coisas lindas e
pelo fato de me encantar com coisas
lindas que eu resolvi seguir na área de
impacto ambiental pelas promessas que a
gente tem a gente tem desde sempre dá
aquela harmonia perfeita aquela
convivência da natureza com o ser humano
e eu acredito fielmente que o mundo está
se tornando um lugar melhor e eu não sou
sinto como eu continuo sentindo que tá
aí o meu propósito de mundo quer mostrar
para as pessoas que a gente pode fazer
do nosso mundo um lugar melhor
muito obrigado
[Música]